les automobilistes qui prennent le
virage électrique le font avant tout
pour des raisons environnementales
mais la question revient souvent la
voiture électrique est elle vraiment
plus verte qu'un véhicule à essence
la réponse est non du moins pas au
départ c'est que la fabrication d'une
voiture électrique à plus d'impact sur
l'environnement que celle d'une voiture
à essence
d'abord parce que le moteur et la
batterie contiennent une foule de
minéraux dont certains sont rares mais
aussi beaucoup de cuivre et d'aluminium
or il a fallu transformer tous ces
matériaux ce qu'ils consomment de
l'énergie et bien souvent ça signifie
brûler des carburants fossiles
cette pollution a des répercussions à
trois niveaux différents
elle accélère des changements
climatiques perturbent les milieux
naturels et causent des problèmes de
santé aux us en comparaison fabriquer un
moteur à combustion à moins d'impact sur
tous ses aspects mais ce qui fait
pencher la balance c'est son utilisation
il faut brûler des milliers de litres
d'essence faire avancer il faut voir la
voiture électrique comme un
investissement environnemental qui se
rentabilise avec le temps un centre de
recherche affilié à polytechnique le
ciraig analysé le cycle de vie complet
d'un véhicule moyen qui roulerait au
québec
la voiture électrique par avec une plus
grande dette environnementale
mais contrairement à la voiture à
essence elle ne pollue presque pas en
roulant après 39 km les émissions
totales de gaz à effet de serre sont
équivalentes
elle marque un point sur le climat
pour ce qui est de l'impact de sa
fabrication sur les milieux naturels
il faut que la voiture électrique roule
dix mille kilomètres de plus pour
atteindre l'équilibré avec la voiture à
essence
pour la santé humaine c'est au bout de
85 mille kilomètres qu'elle devient
moins de sifca véhicules conventionnels
pour qu'une voiture électrique tienne
ses promesses
il faut évidemment que l'électricité
elle-même soit produite de façon
écologique
ce qui n'est pas le cas partout par
exemple une centrale au charbon pollue
beaucoup plus qu'un barrage
hydroélectrique résultats dans certaines
provinces rouler à l'électricité
pourrait être plus nocif pour la santé
est plus dommageable pour les milieux
naturels
par contre pour le climat et les
émissions de co2 dans toutes les
provinces l'électricité serait
préférable à l'essence
et ce serait le cas dans la plupart des
pays sauf par exemple en inde où plus
des deux tiers de l'électricité
proviennent en fait du charbon et en
chine
ce serait match nul les deux types de
voitures émettent à peu près autant de
gaz à effet de serre sur un cycle de vie
complet
c'est d'ailleurs la conclusion qui se
dégage de la plupart des études
la voiture électrique serait moins
dommageable pour le climat que la
voiture à essence
en fait elles marquent des points sont
presque tous sauf les ressources
minérales
c'est son talon d'achille si demain
matin
toutes les voitures et électriques il y
aurait une pression énorme sur certains
minéraux comme le kobalt tools lithium
particulièrement avec les nouveaux
modèles équipés de batteries toujours
plus grosse